Okay,
we should be live here.
Hello folks.
Let me
get the title set.
Man, I used to be able to do those like
10 plus hour days and just get up and do
the same thing again the next day.
That was brutal. That was brutal.
Took me a while to get to sleep. Slept a
whole bunch. Took me a while to get up.
Took me a while to run.
Hang on. Let me get one thing set up.
Then we will uh we'll get started
properly.
I think we're set.
We are. Yeah, we are set.
Oops. One message to answer on the side
and we'll be good.
How did everything go?
How did last night? Yeah, everything is
running. We just have to fix um
Well, there are a few things we have to
fix, I suppose.
much we just have to fix some stuff with
rendering turnbased
and we should be good. And we can kind
of just actually test the important
stuff today.
Fix up our eval. Fix up uh our core
stuff. Clean up this horrible hell of
macro stupidity.
in the next week. No,
we're going to have it set up for the
full release,
but I typically wait a while to make
sure everything is fully stable. Plus,
there's some there's always some release
work to do with writing some blog posts
and such, running benchmarks.
We will have everything stable.
plan is we're going to figure out how to
get nice smooth rendering with neural
MMO.
Ideally, we can do it in a way where the
env is responsible for its own render
loop
and we will go from there.
I think that should work fine. Honestly,
that is the correct design.
Huh?
This is the one I've been waiting for
forever.
Oh, that's very nice.
Thank you,
Hello. Hey,
welcome.
So, as you can see, this is not what the
uh eval is supposed to look like.
There's this there's always been this
annoying discrepancy between the render
loop for web and for desktop. I'd like
to have a clean way to handle this
across all the environments today. I
think that should be reasonably
straightforward to accomplish.
once we have that, we should be able to
uh to do a bit more stuff.
I think what's going to happen is
basically this little macro thing, we're
going to just stick this, we're going to
invert this and put this in the puffer
end thing
and then it'll work across ends.
Uh what I'm doing at the moment, yes, I
have these locally. They're going to be
small enough though that they're going
to be able to be shipped with the
browser,
so you'll just be able to see them on
the website. There are a couple
environments where we'll have to ship a
somewhat lower quality policy to make it
small enough. Probably we won't want to
ship anything more than one or two
million parameters,
whereas some of our environments go up
to maybe 10 mil with what they really
need.
But it should still be pretty good.
Wait, what the [ __ ] Await new promise,
my guy. This is ah file. What are you
doing?
how the [ __ ] does that do anything?
What? Wait,
Does anybody understand how this [ __ ]
works?
Well, this is officially the weirdest
code gen I've ever seen.
M stringifies the body and wraps it in
JS.
It's stringifies.
Oh, okay. So, it's just a literal.
No, no, no, no. It's It's not actually
that interesting. It's just like
removing this and pasting it into JS.
That's still kind of nutty.
Not as big of a deal, though.
Escape is bad.
Not be having escape.
Uh, this also breaks. Okay.
We're basically just going to make sure
that this rendering trick works very
cleanly here. And then we're just going
to apply it across all ends
because this is if it works here, it'll
work everywhere.
Yeah, there we go.
This is how I
designed it, man. Now it works.
Has rendering changed? Nope. This is how
it's always been.
It's just that there were some buggy
[ __ ] going on. This is how I
originally built Neural MMO.
I was super proud of this thing when I
first built it. I still think it's like
the best sim thing I've done.
MMO 4.
Oo, could be
though. I think we're at a point where
we can kind of just like throw puffer at
Runescape.
watching sports ball. What convert?
And I've been moving super slow this
morning. I'm on late today.
I went for a little run. I got some
lifting in. I got some food and some
coffee and I'm feeling a bit better.
Uh, I don't do those competitions, but
people in the puffer community do them.
A dev build.
Dude, have you not seen what Valow's
done?
Like,
he has that
What have we done today?
We've gone for a run, gotten some
lifting, and gotten some breakfast jazz.
Other than that, I'm messing with uh
some rendering fixes, and hopefully
especially rendering fixes for
turn-based games.
Do you have any idea why PO is
particularly good?
People failed to get something better.
Um, I kind of think that's the wrong
the wrong way of looking at it.
So,
it's more so that all the other
directions that people have gone down
make absolutely no damn sense.
Um, on like on policy RL is basically
the only thing that actually
consistently works well. You get a
fairly low variance estimate.
from on Paul data using your value
function. You get a long store a long
form bootstrap through generalized
advantage estimation that you do not get
with other methods.
And the clip term doesn't actually give
you any sort of safety guarantees, but
it does prevent very very bad updates
from immediately crashing things. It
gives you a manner a degree of
robustness.
By comparison,
like off policy is horrendously
inefficient with your compute. It has an
absolutely awful high variance estimate.
It actually relies on data being on
policy in many ways for many of the
advanced techniques and just ignores the
fact that it isn't or attempts to apply
corrections that do not work. Modelbased
approaches are even worse at just
burning unlimited amounts of compute to
learn a much more expensive objective
than just learning a policy.
Anything else I'm missing?
Stuff like hierarchical RL is mostly a
meme.
I think that about covers it.
Rock 4.6. It's fast.
Read my article on X. It has a full list
of papers and things that I recommend.
Ultra opinionated guide to RL.
That article
I will update it at some point, but it's
still pretty like all the information
there is pretty much still good.
I don't know. The modeled questions get
old to me because it's like these things
are completely interchangeable.
It really doesn't matter what token
muncher I'm using.
In my mind, it's like almost as dumb as
if all of the questions that I got were
like, "Why are you using Vim?" Right.
I think people will still ask Jess.
Actually,
I'm not against research in chess,
but the point of the chess project we
have is not to replicate existing work
that like on chess.
It's to test our selfplay and see how
far we can get with that.
I don't know. I'm pretty good at keeping
things straight in my head with uh with
my work. I've been doing it a long time.
No, dude.
No macro conditionals,
please.
I It's the [ __ ] heavy plan, but it's
like
least possible interesting thing going
on right now.
Hang on. I'm just trying to figure out
how we should set the
the frame All right.
I saw it when it came like first was
released to launch. It's a weird mix of
Rust and Python. I'm not really a fan.
That doesn't work. Damn it. I should not
be getting stuck on this.
Hang on. I have to figure I I I'm just
brain is moving slowly this morning or
this day, I guess.
That's better. That's errorp proof.
There's basically no way you can screw
that up.
Why is the web so [ __ ] man?
Why is web so [ __ ]
not really what I want to deal with now,
but this should make it easy to handle
everything else.
Yeah, we're not vendoring core data.
Stupid model,
the working gym.
I'm not in uh that facility at the
moment, but I will be back there later
in the year. I missed the place. It's
very nice.
Even when you don't really have to deal
with browser stuff because you're
writing C, you still have to deal with
browser stuff. Lovely.
We could always just thread it.
Could we
sort of right? We could just thread it
for the bigger M's.
that may not work right because when we
call step it automatically does both.
We should we should prototype this so it
doesn't make a mess.
We'll do um
next four Maybe.
Worth spending a little time on this.
Make a lot of stuff much less janky.
what the problem is with render.
Well, I mean, Jess, for turn-based MS,
right, we want it to be rendering at a
higher FPS so it's responsive.
We also want it to
we'd like it to not show your move and
then the opponent move instantly at the
same time ideally
cuz that's pretty confusing when you're
watching the agent play. And then we
want to make sure it also shows you the
terminal state and we want to do that
without adding a whole bunch of jank
requirements to the ends.
Mhm.
Which papers have you liked most
recently?
I was experimenting with some ideas for
uh from Adam Re for a little bit.
and we'll see whether it looks good and
then we'll see whether we like the
approach.
Unable to find the paper you mentioned.
There's no way. Right. Adam
re RL.
God.
Let's get it to work first and then
we'll see about the uh the imple.
The good news is I I basically only have
to do these two M's and then everything
else will be automatic.
When will it be suitable for locomotion?
You can use it for locomotion. Whatever
state that you have.
Thought you play this yourself. What
this?
No hands.
And then look, this is neural MMO 3.
No hands. But if I hit control now, I
can play it.
So I can go find somebody to fight. This
guy's too strong.
Uh, can I kill level four? Not with a
missing HP. I can't.
So maybe I can find like a level. This
guy will wreck me. Let's not get low
close to him. Oh, oops. You get one
shot.
All right, let's see if I can be better
at my own game.
This guy is also going to wreck me.
Maybe a level four.
Nope. The highest you can beat at level
one's level three, I believe.
Okay, now you get a tool.
Now I can equip this tool. I can get
armor here.
I can equip this. I can get a sword.
Take this off. Put this on. And now I
can hit control And I can let the agent
play and we can see what it decides it
should do with all of the equipment I've
just given it.
Torch and Isaac lab. Yeah, that's a
rough uh robotic stack is pretty rough.
You kind of have to commit to building a
lot of your own simulation tooling is
the thing to replace it. But if I were
in robotics, I would absolutely be
building my own sim stack for that.
One of the most impressive projects.
Thank you.
How's the game connect to RL?
This is an agent playing it.
Did it work? Anyone puffer done? Work
with the Google football sim?
No, because it's kind of slow. If you
wanted a soccer sim, you'd build one
yourself. That's better. Um, Kinvert did
a super janky one lately.
We've done similar stuff, but building a
good one for that would be some work.
It would be some work.
Uh
source.
What am I doing here? Ocean connect
four. Obviously
412 to 47. Wait, 472 lines.
Did it get shorter?
It did get shorter. How did it get
shorter?
I would definitely mess with this. I'm
actually confused.
few weeks for 5 most likely
before I leave California for the
summer.
Hopefully it doesn't go try to refactor
the entire bloody
right. This and then we apply to
everything and we should be good.
I did want to look at uh one thing
because we've gotten a couple PRs where
people have actually like
cleaned up
Like what are they doing here to make
these look nice? Is this literally just
is this a texture
or is this rayb?
It's just to draw a circle.
Okay.
I think this also needs um
anti-aliasing.
right. This is basically what we were
trying to get to for the first couple
hours here, right? We went and we
figured out a clean way to handle
uh to handle
the rendering jank for turn-based and
non-turnbased environments on web.
Right? We came up with like minimally
invasive ways to do that.
And now since we have those two clean
examples, we're just going to map that
onto everything. And then essentially
this should be adding almost no code.
And if it's adding any code, we prevent
it from making a mess.
And that's it. That's all we need.
After this, we can actually go on to
hopefully clean up some core code.
right,
I will be right back. I'm use the
restroom and grab a
This should essentially be
this should be a tiny diff.
In fact, I can basically get this thing
auto checked.
Yeah, I can literally just check this
stuff automatically. I did all of the
manual checking work yesterday.
I did it all yesterday. We're good.
Yeah, I It's funny you mentioned that.
That's actually the next thing I was
thinking of. I want to see whether that
fixes it on its own or not,
but let's get this done first.
We could probably just add that at the
web demo level to be fair.
Um,
hello.
Just check all the M's.
Is that a smoothie? No, that's a coffee.
did I did I make mobile for 60 fps? I
forget.
Use the FPV drone race. I told him to
look this up.
Thank you.
Thank you for starring the puffer as
well.
Star the puffer. Puffer likes stars.
doing demo nerd sniped him. Oh, Puffer's
gotten so much better since uh since
some of those demo videos. Unless the 40
demo is pretty good.
10 launch. Oh my gosh, we've gotten
stuff so much better since then. Check
the drone uh demo on our website now.
volley is fine.
I just have to double check all the Ms.
Okay,
I just have to make sure nothing broke.
constellation has log shape
a lot.
I'm not seeing things. What?
Well, it has log shape because it's log
scale, right?
So if we just pick an N here
right it's like log linear
can switch this to be linear
and then yeah you get this log curve you
can switch to score which will give you
the full scale
can also do it in steps
that one's funny enough a little flatter
there,
All right, those are all the minor
fixes.
I'm hoping this will be essentially zero
bloat and jank. Maybe a couple ms will
need a little bit of work, but we're
essentially I'm just going to check the
um the line count diff across everything
and a couple other things. We checked
everything manually for all the big
changes yesterday, remember?
and we will be good.
It's currently 300 p.m. So, if we can
finish this in the next hour or so,
gives us a couple hours
to go through core code.
Yeah, it's not
it's really not like consumer tech in
that way.
Like if you need a gooey,
like you're probably not the uh the
target audience for it.
there might be something there.
I will think about that.
almost done.
We will double check this
and then obviously we'll make sure that
nothing got completely screwed up in the
process.
Heavy work day was yesterday for the
most part.
I wonder if the one that's supposed to
move the uh the site worked.
Yeah. Okay.
We have over 60 environments. That's
crazy.
We have over 60 ends.
Okay, everything except tower climb
items should be good. So, we can at
least check this in the background.
We don't need to. Okay, this is fine.
What the [ __ ] is this and why is it
important? This is the highest
performance reinforcement learning
library out there. And it is important
because interaction is fundamental to
intelligence.
Another way of looking at it is there
are a whole bunch of fiddly unintuitive
problems that really matter. And the
best way to solve them is by simulating
stupidly big amounts of data and then
chucking RL at it. The problem is RL is
janky and generally doesn't work. Except
now it does because puffer lip exists.
A lot of our tasks are games because
games are really good for research. But
um you know flying drone, driving car,
navigating fiddly whatever other
industrial sim, the tech kind of doesn't
care.
And learn this in a week. You will not
be able to learn all of this stuff in a
week. However, if you have any sort of
reasonable programming background, you
will be able to make a decent little
environment or two in a week and learn
quite a bit about the field. I have
educational materials uh available on my
X under the articles tab for free.
All of this is open source
and you can train most of these models
on like a 10- cent per hour GPU off of
AST.
I am currently just auditing a bunch of
changes to make sure nothing is broken
prior to our big upcoming release.
Okay, this one's still broken, but this
one we know is broken.
This one I think is laggy because of the
model.
Yep, it's C. It's really simple C
though. Oh, is this fixed now?
No,
it's very, very simple. See,
like if you ever took an intro systems
course, you're good to go.
And we've also had many people learn
enough uh to get started that had not
fish simulator.
I like that one.
I'm just making sure that nothing got
broken.
Okay, chest is nice now.
Yeah, chest just works.
Checkers. I also do review um I do
review NVPRs on stream from new
contributors, provided it's not like
100% vibecoded crap, provided there was
actual like thought and effort that went
into it.
train on machines.
Uh, so as of 5, so in 40 you can
technically train on CPU. Yes, in 5,
we've removed that ability because it
really wasn't worth it. It's so
incredibly slow and unwieldy.
Instead, as of 5, we suggest that you
rent a 10-cent per hour GPU off of Vast.
Like if you're really strapped for cash,
just rent a 10-centent per hour GPU off
of AST. And we give you local evaluation
that works on CPU without needing a GPU.
You can eval whatever you want locally,
but training is CUDA only.
How do I I differentiate if it's vibe
coded or not?
If I look at the code and it's complete
and utter ass and it has all the signs
of being asked because it's stupid
language model jank, they have very
common error patterns, then I will flame
you. If it's like crap code because
you're genuinely a beginner, um I will
give harsh feedback, but I will give
useful constructive advice.
And if it's generally decent, I will
give advice on how to improve. And uh
once the quality bar on code is met and
people are generally submitting things
that are competently made, I will give
deeper feedback on finer points of RL
environment design.
Most of the environments at this point
are by contributors.
This model's bad, I think. Right. Yeah,
this model's bad, but it's fine.
Does this look slightly off to you?
The speeds look kind of weird to me.
Like sometimes it runs fast, sometimes
it runs slow, right?
But then this, which is basically the
same environment, looks good to me.
It might just be policy size.
I also I thought we had a double
pendulum policy that solves.
It shouldn't be getting reward for doing
that.
Oh, it's not. It's trying to balance.
That's funny.
This one is so funny.
I I didn't want to merge one of these
like silly little flappy bird ends.
Okay, there's definitely something going
on with like weird weird variable run
speed.
Why do you see this going down the line?
hopefully solving an important uh a
number of important problems in science
that are heavily reliant on having
simulation working well.
And why open source? Because it needs to
exist. And I figure I can make money
anyways.
Puffer is a company.
Other companies can hire us to build
them incredibly high performance
reinforcement learning sims to just flat
out solve RL problems that they have or
to integrate our tech with uh their
internal stuff.
But we have a number of professional
services available.
turnbased ends. Yes,
it's uh it's for any turn-based end.
There was just some rendering details
that needed to be handled. arch.
How do you determine it's turnbased?
No, no, no. Each NV still has to
implement a thing arch. But now we made
it we made it pretty easy to handle
turnbased render
without having to impose a bunch of
extra stuff.
It's not like automatic or anything, but
we just came up with a cleaner way of
doing it.
Unless I'm not understanding it.
I might just not be understanding it.
Chin reaction animations are too fast
under this.
Oh, I think it's because we have.3
seconds.
Oh, that's kind of fine, though. I kind
of like it.
Okay, that's cool. I like it. I like it.
That's cool.
Honestly, very basic stuff like how they
just drew a couple gradients and circles
and the uh the orbs look way better. It
kind of gets me thinking uh we should
actually bother to do that.
So hopefully we don't get penalized for
this. We will see.
I'll basically just have to audit these
ones. So, I'll have like 10 M's to
audit.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. Yeah, 10 M. That's
not bad.
Basically, no. No. Uh, no substantial
additions required for this for all but
10 of the environments.
We actually have lots of nice self plans
if you think about it. Now look, Roboc
code. That's one. We've got chess and
go. That's pretty good, right? We've got
checkers hex. This one's kind of easy.
Uh slime volley.
Chain reaction bat gammon
arguably this antsen Tron gorilla
checkers
we have a lot of nice self plans for
testing now
So yeah, we're basically on time. We'll
be able to have about 2 hours before
dinner to go through the core, which
will be the tougher work. I'll have to
sit up for that.
First, we got to make sure nothing else
is screwed up. We commit this and then
we'll do the shared section.
Oh yeah, let's take a look at um
anti-alias version.
Maybe not ideal for text on some of
these. Pretty
good overall, I'd say.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Everything looks just
way cleaner now, right?
Yep.
I'm happy with that.
And the text actually doesn't look bad
either.
Good papers on pre-training.
There really aren't good. I mean, unless
you mean LLM stuff, which is not my
area, there really is not pre-training
for RL.
And the reason for that is we typically
we use RL for lots of different fiddly
problems.
So there really isn't that much
opportunity for knowledge transfer.
You're way better off just having a fast
sim and training a fast task specific
model.
We do retrain from scratch and it's
fast.
It's very fast. Any of these RLM
startups trying to buy you out? No,
because we're in a different area
and frankly we're not really trying to
be bought out either. That's not the
point of what I'm doing.
I really foresee us just having like a
small profitable lab where we get to
advance science meaningfully.
Um, companies that are doing stuff in
adjacent areas will have cause to hire
our services. In fact, they already do.
And we're kind of just generally free to
really make some meaningful scientific
advances without having to have a bunch
of annoyances and strings and extras
attached.
I don't get that. I need curriculum.
Well, one funny thing with neural MMO,
which I suspected for a while, but
actually was finally patched, submitted
and patched,
there was a pretty big bug. So, we got
Soda with 1,000th of the computive
before over the last couple of days.
It's still a billion steps. So, it still
plays like whatever that is 20 years
worth of neural MMO. And we're still
going to scale it up so it plays like
2,000 years of neural MMO as well.
But, um, training is very fast.
Training is very fast.
You kind of just don't need to worry
about it. Yeah, service is a service.
Isn't that funny how what a shocking
business model is? Wait, you're telling
me we don't have to pay for some
[ __ ] subscription? It's just we pay
the service. Is it because it's a
service?
Yeah.
Mind you, it's not a cheap service, but
we provide very good value on on the
work that we do.
We can really solve a lot of problems.
We have lots of envir curriculum, man.
But pre-training is not how you apply
curriculum in RL.
Like here's a good example of that for
you, mate.
Here's this maze ends, right?
You see how every time it solves it's a
different maze and it's a different
size. If you try to solve the fulls size
maze from the start, you'll never solve
it because random actions will never get
a reward. It'll take billions and
billions of steps and they'll never get
a reward. But if you train it on random
size mazes, and this policy is not the
uh the strong one. Our actual policy has
a 100% solve rate on all the mazes. Um
if you train it on all the different
sizes, that's the curriculum.
So the curriculum is actually built into
the structure of the task. That's how
you do it in RL.
First, it needed to be able to
manipulate Legos.
Yeah, exactly. You can just, you know,
you can just train it on a lot of
different tasks of varying difficulty at
the same time. It doesn't need to be a
pre-trained model. In fact, I'd very
strongly advise not using pre-trained
models in RL because then you end up
with the whole continual learning mess
[ __ ] problem. It's so much easier to
just train something multitask
that gives you a curriculum in most
cases.
If you train your policy, you can reuse
it, so you don't need to spend more
compute. All right. So, this is the
thing that the the LLM people are trying
to sell you, right? If you pre-train the
policy and it can do lots of different
things, then you don't need to retrain
it. So, it's cheap. But then they're
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
and our stuff trains in seconds on one
GPU.
So, who's wasting compute?
Also, you can train multitask policies.
That is a thing. You still don't need
pre-training.
Does Mok and Isaac are bad? Yep, that's
pretty much the case. If the Sim is
slow, you have nothing to do. You make
the Sim fast.
We do that professionally, you know.
Oh, the number of times I've had people
say, "Oh, no. It's very complicated
simulator. You can't make it faster."
And then we come back a week later like,
"Here's a lowfi version. It trains a
thousandx faster. Here's it working on
your problem.
Rewrite physics sims. If I were going to
be deep into robotics, then yes, I would
absolutely be writing my own sim.
I don't know how efficient warp is and
whether I would use it as a backend or
not or whether I would just take some
inspiration from it. I sure as hell
wouldn't be building on any of the big
platforms though. Those are awful.
I don't doubt that you totally could
make it fold laundry fast in SM. Um, in
my mind, that's just a very stupid
problem. So, like
if somebody really wants to hire us to
do that and like sure, I guess, but
they're just cooler and more important
problems to be solving.
By all means though, if one of our
contributors wants to go like throw
together some robotics demos to sty me a
bunch of robotics folks, like go ahead.
There's really nothing unique about
robotics where it's like, oh no, you
like you absolutely can't do it here.
It's just that robotics is an area that
has already has an annoyingly deep
stack. So it would be quite a bit of
work to set something up.
Um
I doubt it would be more work than like
let's say Volo is done for Runescape
though. Probably less work than that.
But I actually consider the Runescape
environment to be more important than
humanoid robotics. You can mle that one
over
path for humanoid robot to get to human
level intelligence.
Well, you can just take the robot
portion out of that entirely, right?
Like you're simply not going to have
human level intelligence like a robot or
otherwise with current approaches.
The language models do not have general
intelligence. They have narrow
intelligence.
I also don't think it's important. I
really don't.
It does 99% of jobs.
Well,
the one the specific 1% in missing
happens to comprise like basically all
of the problems that I care about.
So,
like actually making tons of stuff super
cheap and efficient or like massively
advancing science or solving disease.
That's not the way that I see it. That's
I just I suppose I see the world very
differently.
Okay, it just it had to add this one ply
thing. It's not terrible though.
I mean, having humanoids building stuff
in a factory is just so incredibly
stupid to me.
Like, I'm sure that people will do it
and I'm sure it will make a bunch of
money. That doesn't make it not
completely dumb.
I mean, look at what language models are
doing now. People are shoving language
models into all sorts of applications
where they make absolutely no sense and
paying lots of money to do it. Like that
doesn't make it All right.
I really don't like
No, this is bad.
Okay, we have to re We have to figure
this thing out.
How much do I spend on tokens?
Whatever the sub price is divided by 30,
like $10
or like $3. People
like money. Oh, I like money, too. But
the things that I want most in life are
not things that I can buy with money. At
least not yet.
Let me know when money can cure aging
and prevent all disease and such.
Then I will be very very interested in
money.
to do research at open anthropic. No,
because the job would probably be very
miserable. Those are they pretend that
they're labs, but they're not really
labs anymore. They're just big
companies. They were actually labs back
when they had like a hundred people.
Openai was awesome when it had like a
hundred people.
That'd be fun to discover that and then
just go sell that for like $5 or
something.
Yeah, 5 time 7 billion is still a lot of
dollars.
I'm also not beta testing medicine.
That just seems
not smart.
Hang on. I actually have to figure this
out because this snapshot thing is
really jank.
I'm going to be honest. I don't think
this is worth it.
I really don't think this snapshot stuff
is worth it. We can fix all the other
ends.
Let me use a restroom real quick.
I'm glad we didn't commit that.
I've been doing RL since like 2017 or
something.
You can look at some of the stuff from
my thesis as to why I think it's
important long term. The short version
is just interactivity is fundamental to
intelligence.
And then as I worked more on it, it
became very clear that there's a wide
set of problems where this seems like
really the only viable solution.
There's a lot of jank in the field and
very many large subsections of it just
fundamentally do not work and all the
lit is wrong.
But at least with the approach we have
now, things are working, things are fast
and things are stable. The progress has
been great.
Honestly, more has happened in the last
couple years around with Puffer than
I've seen happen the whole decade prior.
There's still a few problems left
unsolved, but I think overall it's it's
very close to just being mature, stable,
mature and ta stable tech. Arguably, it
might even be so now and I just am
setting too high of a threshold,
but certainly in the next here.
Why is there no um research on timeline
today?
All right, chess going well. Oh, I
missed that totally. Um,
you can ask Jess about chess. I'm not
trying to like make a good chess policy
at the moment. Jess has that project and
we will use that uh when we do more
selfplay stuff.
I'm mostly just cleaning up all of the
environments for release, which includes
integrating chess, but that's about it
at the moment.
I mean, we have 60 plus environments.
Give me a break. I got to merge a lot of
stuff in. Look, check this out. Okay, so
this is the live version of Puffer. This
is the number of environments we have.
You see? Okay, now check out the number
of environments we have here.
you're kind of just screwed in LLM RL.
Like that's not a good algorithm in
general RL at all,
but they can't train value function, so
they're just screwed.
I'm dropping the um the sequential move
thing for environments where it makes a
mess of the code.
Sometimes the best thing you can do is
know when a feature is not worth it.
We still have a lot of M's where it just
works. How
do I get rid of this button? There you
go.
non-game ends
drone
drive
weekly electric fish simulator.
There'll be blog on this soon.
I think we have one more in here, don't
we?
Oh, there are a few like sort of semium
like the antsen and stuff. And I've been
meaning to actually look at this.
Apparently, this is some quantum
mechanics thing.
I need to understand this better though
to actually fix this.
And when I say apparently, it's it's
actually from somebody who knows what
he's doing.
There need to wait.
No, you don't need to wait. Start
writing an N.
You can write it on forro if you want
like The changes on the end from four to
five are really basic. It'll be very
simple to port stuff.
Yeah, they just these agents just do
[ __ ] things. I don't know. It's
weird.
I verse open code.
I'm not using either of those, dude.
Is it just rock?
Client of like cast one to CL. But what
the hell, right?
Well, whatever. It takes us like an
extra half hour hour than I would have
liked, but we'll get it done.
Kind of stupid.
Yeah, this this and this very stupid.
We'll fix that.
Hello, Jess.
We got a clean thing for some of the
turnbased MS, but for the more complex
ones, it's not worth it.
It adds like a between 50 and 100 lines
of really dumb jank state snapshot
[ __ ]
We'd essenti we'd have to make a much
more major change to the way that the
puffer like library as a whole works and
it's really just not worth.
So ends where we can trivially just um
make the moves obviously more
sequential. We will
and anywhere we can't
whatever it'll just be like simultaneous
Okay.
This should all end up being minimal
diffs.
We still get our render fixes.
It is fine.
And we just have to deal with our core
diff
That one will be that one will be a
little difficult.
Agriculture did okay.
Can't get even get it going again.
Did okay, but hard can't get it going
again.
Suddenly not working at 512 would just
Yeah, that would just be a hyper shift.
You pretty much should never just
increase the model size and then have
everything break,
particularly not with MUP,
but you can shift some hypers,
especially if you're in an unstable
regime.
From what I saw from that competition,
it's mostly not implementing a shitty
deceptive reward
and also obviously having OBS and action
spaces formulated correctly.
What the hell is happening here? Are we
done?
No,
we're just spinning forever being
stupid. Huh?
Oh, there we go.
No.
the EAG target.
Oh, did that work? That's a very nice
data point to have because we're pretty
interested in applying that technique
more widely.
I have a feeling it just broke
everything. We'll see.
It's weird. Like, I have it on medium,
so it's fast, but like I don't It
shouldn't ever even be spinning for 9
minutes.
really annoying day.
We did figure out I mean to be fair this
this day started dealing with a very
janky obnoxious rendering issue.
I thought we were going to be able to do
something better for turnbased
because of this, but I mean we still
like five of the M's have simple
turnbased like nice render
and some of them there's just not a good
way to do it which is fine.
As long as this works from here, we'll
just commit this and then we will look
at shared There
is this when I'm a subscriber.
Somebody donated some subs like right as
I closed this stream yesterday, I think.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that's what
happened either way.
Hopefully, this should now be just tiny,
tiny, tiny fixes. We went on a little
bit of a tangent, but we did end up
fixing like 5 m out of it. I don't know
whether it was worth it or not, but it's
fine.
we double check, we push everything, and
we deal with core,
which is basically all the really simple
um two-player games where it's trivial
to rewind one action.
Those ones will render nicely and
sequentially,
and the ones that change a lot of state
will not.
That should actually include chest to be
fair.
Uncertain whether it does
then that should be easy. Jess, I I
don't know whether it's implemented or
not. Um, I will take a look at that at
some point if it isn't already.
We have like 60 M though
that I would like to see expanded. This
ants env
my own minimal env. I need to do a
little work on
asteroids for sure
chest
craft decks. Lots of Ms.
I should be able to deal with it. Jess,
it's pretty simple.
soon as we start using chess for
selfplay stuff And
I thought um Ben Finn's working on
conditional action trees.
Okay, this is good.
Let's just double check that all the M's
work and we'll be we'll be done.
This is loading too big of a policy.
Oh yeah, this end as well. I need to
finish.
It just [ __ ] everything up somehow like
no matter what. It's kind of impressive
honestly.
Go back through these again.
Good.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is definitely
broken.
I think we'll commit from here as long
as this is fixed.
I'm tired and I'd like to have at least
an hour to do some core work.
This is a pretty small for 60 m.
I think we did uh we did all right on
our fixes today.
supposed to inspire me to go on a diet
thousand calories a day now.
Uh, that might be very aggressive.
Even my 1500 calorie a day diet, like
my 1500 calorie per day cut, I was still
eating like 1,500 calories.
100 a,000 is a bit more than psychotic.
That might be a little dangerous.
I don't know. If you're like, if you
weigh 120 pounds, it might be fine.
just be a little careful with it. But
yes, generally heavy cut is good.
Running is very good.
You pretty much want you can cut as much
as you want up until the point where
that you're like completely crashing all
your hormones and just feel awful.
You shouldn't just feel awful.
Definitely you feel a bit fatigued,
especially after a few weeks,
but it shouldn't be completely
miserable.
The running should be more miserable
than the diet. Let's put it that way.
But yeah, good on you. Fitness is
important.
I actually I checked today because I've
lost a lot of weight. So, I was hoping I
didn't lose too much strength.
I weigh like 171 and I can still bench
two plates for five. I could bench two
plates for 10 at like 183 184 lbs at the
start of the summer. So that's not bad
for having lost over 10 lbs.
It really depends on the training block
I'm doing. This summer has been, I'd
say, relatively chill. I did a 5K this
morning and then I did uh I did some
lifting.
the dish is uh well the main trail where
I run is closed for a little bit. That's
where I normally run 10ks.
Most of the summer I've been running at
least a couple 10ks and a couple 5ks a
week.
A serious training block I would
probably be running a minimum of 30
miles a week.
Somewhere between 30 and 45.
But this summer, it's mostly just been
do a little bit of cardio, do a little
bit of strength, do a decent cut. That's
about it.
just debloating a couple small things.
Just sneaks all these little stupid
changes in, you know.
original Perf weights didn't account
enough for highest level of difficulty.
Okay,
I have to still look at it. Convert.
I've been stuck dealing with horseshit
today.
just mentioned me. He got you confused
with Finn on some other thing.
Okay,
that's fine.
I'm hoping most of this code just goes
away.
I'm use a restroom real quick while this
runs.
We'll see whether this is a just all
bloat or whether I actually have to
Well, we'll check in the meantime, I
suppose.
Okay, there's some legitimate stuff in
here.
Yep. That's good. That gets rid of half
of the bloat
at least. And then I get to check it
from there.
That would be nice
Yeah, 250 lines.
And then obviously I know that I have in
puffer end I have a bunch of more cuts
to make. So we'll still be shipping 10k.
That's good.
Okay.
Hopefully,
I mean, we'll have to check obviously,
but hopefully
we minify
typically bagel sandwich and a
minestrone soup for breakfast, no lunch,
and um
either like some lean steak and rice um
from Mexican place or a big bowl of like
chicken and rice soup
for dinner.
A few extras depending on energy levels
and extra and exercise for the day.
I was feeling kind of beat up this
morning, so I got a couple of um like
biscuit cookies with uh with my morning
coffee before I ran.
Usually a couple times a week, if I've
done like a bunch of running or, you
know, I'm just generally feeling kind of
beat up, I'll get like an extra pastry
or something with breakfast. That
usually evens everything out. But
otherwise, it's pretty good.
What are we doing here? Oh, we're just
moving stuff around. That's fine.
Just removing some bloat here. We'll get
it down to close to 10k lines and then
once I finish all the puffer fish,
mascot, whatever changes, it'll
definitely be sub 10k lines and that'll
be the release.
Arguably, there's some changes to
constellation, but we're pretty much
done with all the major
just like let's just do a bunch of
[ __ ] for no reason.
I mean, this is the stuff where it's
like these things are not generally
intelligent.
They just make all sorts of really dumb
decisions.
Like if you asked anybody to do this,
they would like copy paste the C code
for screenshot and figure out what other
minimal stuff that you need in order to
make it run, right?
And now this thing starts like I wonder
if we can install NodeJS.
I'm like, what?
Look at that. Boom. Boom. Boom boom. All
this stuff comes out of Here.
fire.
I It's like I don't understand why it's
like here's a screenshot script and C
port this into a standalone. It's like
ah yes, let's make a standalone with the
lightest dependency ever. NodeJS.
Like what the hell is wrong with you?
I don't know. We like forgive these
errors I think a lot more in language
models because it's very quick to just
say no no no do it this way. But like if
you gave this task to a coworker or
whatever and then they came back with
this dumb [ __ ] you just look at
them just like why the hell do we have
you around again?
auto research.
So basically any time I've tried to let
models do any form of semi even
semiautonomous research, they will come
back with something that looks good and
then takes me four hours to figure out
is completely and utterly invalid.
I don't know. You kind of have to be
smart like a little bit to do good
research.
Yeah. Well, that's the thing. Twitter's
not the real world.
People in SF are so incredibly out of
touch. It's honestly kind of unbearable.
I sort of used to like being around this
area, like even going into SF once in a
while to see what was happening, but
it's just it's such a big perversion of
the field at this point. It's [ __ ]
It's kind of feels like just it's like
LA almost. It's like Hollywood,
except instead of it being like movie
fake status stuff, it's like fake tech
that doesn't actually work status
[ __ ]
and I'm not saying that the models
aren't useful, right? The models are
very useful,
but I mean it's like it's kind of like
if I were to go around claiming that
Puffer models are AGI, right? It's like,
oh yeah, we we have AGI your service.
It's like, well, our models are very
useful, but nope. They're narrow, right?
They're narrow task specific models.
timelines. Oh, I have a great definition
of AGI. And unlike everybody else, I
haven't changed my definition every
year.
Let me show you.
I love when somebody gives me an excuse
to bring this up.
Here's
my definition of AGI. Okay,
this was published in 2024,
but like I came up with this in I think
2017 or 2018 at OpenAI.
Here you go.
Why, dude? I literally have the wro
above my head floating in text and ah
why do people still ask me this? It's
faster. That's literally it. It's not
that complicated.
Damn it. Let's see.
Rock AGI. No.
Does it let me cast fireball?
Doesn't let me cast fireball, does it?
Eventually, we're gonna get a model that
lets me cast fireball.
There's actually an article behind that
that makes some amount of sense. It's
not totally just a meme.
It also has the uh the really useful
side effect of preventing people from
moving the damn goalpost constantly,
which is Nice.
I believe so. crit.
I'm kind of tired and I'm going to have
to check a few more things, but overall
pretty
LM RL.
I mean, I kind of like to troll the LLM
people by saying it's stupid baby mode
RL for stupid babies.
Realistically, it's not like the thing
that they're doing is dumb. It's just
that the whole problem formulation is
dumb and prevents you from doing
anything meaningful other than just like
burning as many dollars as possible on a
really shitty signal. Oh,
I probably been cutting 1k for a good
number of the last few weeks.
Two meals.
It It's kind of more fundamentally
screwed with the LM stuff.
There might be some clever way, but I
they probably need to just massively
reformulate things. It's not going to
just be simple, I wouldn't think.
I refuse to believe this is not just
like loading a castle asset or at the
very least a very like large piece set
and plunking everything down.
It depends how much money they're
willing to burn.
>> They can say as much as it takes, but at
some point they run out of money.
like the M. We have lots of M that need
improvement. Cret,
is it a person or technology decides
what comments are displayed on the
channel? So because I use reream.
So YouTube, Twitch, and X all have their
own automatic like I have not enabled
anything like I have not enabled any
additional filters, but they all have
their own automatic filtering. And then
Reream occasionally like screws up and
drops messages as well. So, nobody is
actively trying to drop messages,
but some of the platforms definitely
have random filters on off.
just getting rid of Jank.
Yeah, we don't need any of this.
Oh yeah, by the way, this
this is totally allowed.
Hey, there's still some bloat.
There's still some bloat.
Um, I mean it will be funny in the sense
that like RL will do very very well at
it and it's very hard for people to
play.
It honestly would be pretty fun to have
that as an N
I don't know whether it would be trivial
or not. It's kind of interesting in the
sense that they're like lots of jumps
that you need to practice. It might have
an interesting learning pattern to it.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Particularly if you made it actually
good and could load the real maps.
MIT who
1998.
Welcome
experimenting with agents.
Uh you can do that for very simple ends
that will rapidly become a mess for
anything substantial.
Cannot live without the garbage
collector. All right, let me let me tell
you how we do memory management around
here. All right, we allocate all the
memory we need at the start of the
program on initialization.
We don't allocate anything during the
main loop of the program whatsoever.
And that's it. That's memory management.
It's very easy.
Like most of the need for memory
management is higher level languages
just allocating everything everywhere.
You don't even need an arena is the
crazy thing. You don't even need that.
Did you know that you don't actually
have to free your memory if it's
supposed to be there for the lifetime of
the program? The OS will free it for
you. The only memory that you have to
free is like dynamically growing memory,
which most of the time you just should
not have.
Isn't that funny how we just cut off
like 550 lines of jank that the LLM
added?
And we're back under 10,000 lines for
the entire object.
That's a small program.
I mean, it's the highest performance
reinforcement learning library.
Like obviously it took a lot of work to
design the entire thing in static
memory, but we designed the entire thing
in static memory.
And yes, generally string functions
allocating everywhere is a mess. They
should not be doing that.
There are a couple places where it's
unavoidable and you do have to do a
little bit of memory management. We have
that with I think the config loader, but
that's pretty much the only place.
Ah, that's fun.
Yeah, if you're doing a lot of heavy
work with strings, it gets to be
annoying.
Still though, memory management, manu
manual memory management is still not
that hard, even when you do have to
actually do it.
I generally don't like having um
functions that dynamically allocate
memory that are going to be called in a
loop that like return allocations.
I typically prefer to have the caller
uh allocate the memory, pass the memory
in to whatever and then clean it up
itself.
I'm kind of tired for the day. I think
this is enough.
I've gotten it back under 10k lines
again. There's still some macro jank at
the bottom here I want to clean up.
Allocate memory is not in my vocabulary.
Uh,
no. I think garbage collection is
basically a non-starter for my work.
We do ultra high performance simulation
and generally for what I do, I'm very
very happy with C.
I wrote Python for like a decade.
Awful.
Everything just feels so much easier and
so much simpler. And see, cuz you don't
need to workarounds to get high
performance. You just get high
performance.
just few seconds or two mean nothing.
Well, when we train at 60 million steps
per second,
one additional microscond in our hot
loop completely crushes performance.
We have to care about micro seconds over
batches of datas and nanconds
on the individual end of path.
This is still 4.6 million SPS on a 3080
without GPU mode enabled for the N
in DMC.
Yeah, thing is a mess.
Well, hopefully there's some
entertainment for you then.
We are working on some pretty cool tech
though. At the moment, this is mostly
janitorial work.
I think that's my cue for today.
Are we meing here?
I really don't like anything whatsoever
about Rust.
I'm happy for now, guys.
There might be some obvious broken
things. I'm going to have to check this
when I'm fresh, but um
50 is pushed. Oh, I forgot the the build
script.
Hang on. Let me let me make sure I have
Metley's pushing build and stuff.
Let me just push this.
Memory safety.
Not a feature that you actually need.
Makes you write really awful janky code.
Blleh.
Is this AI training? Yes, we're training
models.
Our
models are very small and train very
fast. If you'd like to learn more, we
have demos on puffer.ai.
These are all models that run in your
browser. They're tiny. This is not
running on our server. This is just
running live on a single thread in your
browser.
We have some puzzle games.
We have some non-game tasks like drone
and driving,
It's been a long weekend with uh with
all the work. I know today was a
somewhat shorter day actually. How long
did I stream so far today?
Five hours. Five like five and a half
hours.
We're going to see how I feel. I may or
may not do an evening stream today.
I am going to be live tomorrow. I have
some work that I want to finish on this
tomorrow with Net Hack especially.
Tomorrow might be a good day to do some
net hack. We will see.
I also just generally want to make sure
that the release is not janky.
We do have some sweeps to orchestrate
and such.
Should be good overall though.
Well, thank you everyone for tuning in.
Um,
all the folks on YouTube and Twitch,
if you're interested in my stuff
generally, puffer.ai star the puffer on
GitHub. helps out a lot for free.